هناك شاي تشاي هندي ، شاي أخضر ياباني
وبالطبع شاي أسود إنكليزي ، لكن
يمكن أن يكون مفيدًا لك إذا قمت بتخميره في
المنزل وابتعدت عن
الشاي المعلب والمعبأ في زجاجات المحلاة مسبقًا
الآن الشاي الأسود والأخضر والأبيض هم جميعًا
تأتي من نفس نباتات شاي الكاميليا
سينينسيس
العشبية مثل البابونج أو شاي النعناع التي
لا تأتي من هذا النبات
لذلك ليس لديهم نفس
الفوائد الصحية لأن البوليفينول الموجود في
الشاي الأسود والأبيض والأخضر له
خصائص مضادة للالتهابات ومضادة
للأكسدة.  إعادة ربطها
بالوقاية من أمراض القلب والسكري
وربما
السرطان ، لذا إذا كانت تأتي من نفس
النبات ،
فما الفرق بين
الشاي الأسود والأخضر والأبيض
جيدًا ، فإن الطريقة التي تتم معالجتها
بشرب الشاي آمنة جدًا بشكل عام
ولكن قد يكون بعض الأشخاص حساسين تجاهها.
قد يحتوي شاي الكافيين أيضًا على فيتامين ك ، لذا إذا
كنت تتناول أدوية مميعة للدم ،
يجب عليك استشارة طبيبك أولاً